il est 9h15 ce 16 septembre 2016 quand
une explosion ravageait un immeuble
d'une vingtaine de logements au 15 de la
rue pierre palio à dijon très vite une
soixantaine de pompiers s'activent dans
les décombres et en fin de matinée on
est en mesure de dresser un premier
bilan
une vingtaine de victimes ont été
dénombrées
parmi elles 15 blessés dont deux plus
sérieusement impactée plus que c'est une
bombe truc énorme
c'était horrible donc la jeune mathilde
ouazine qui a traumatisé mais bon on si
on avait été dans les parties derrière
on était mort franchement la victime la
plus touchée devrait être amputé d'une
jambe
très vite la piste terroriste est
écartée parmi les blessés un homme d'une
cinquantaine d'années déclare avoir
tenté de se suicider par le gaz et
reconnaît être à l'origine de
l'explosion
il comparaît aujourd'hui pour
destruction du bien d'autrui par des
moyens dangereux avec des circonstances
aggravantes et notamment celle d'avoir
entraîné la mutilation d'une victime
ils risquent une peine de 30 ans de
réclusion